And the first question I have for you is
as we've often been doing first
question, what is the meaning of the
term?
And can you give us the differentiation
between that term and which is often
misconstrued?
Alhamdulillah.
As far as the word is concerned, it is
broken up into two words.
Kam means to stand
and al means the night. So literally it
means standing in the night. But in the
Sharia
in the Islamic context it means it is a
voluntary prayer which is prayed after
isha and before the break of dawn.
And as we aware that Isha starts after
the redness of the sky disappears after
sunset and you can pray this
just before the break of dawn before the
time of fud.
So the wordam was given because a person
in this voluntary prayer he recites long
verses of the Quran. So the standing is
long. Therefore it is called as standing
in the night. The prayer where you have
to stand for a long time. And there are
various different words
which are used for the same. For
example, it's also called asatal meaning
the prayer at night. It's also called as
it's also called as var also asawi.
Salatal as I mentioned means prayer at
night similar to standing in the night
but nach for praying.
The other word used is coming from the
word hajada which means to wake up. So
when a person sleeps and he wakes up to
pray it's called as also
the other word used is var meaning odd
and a prophet always say that we have to
after is salah you should offer in odd
raats and the other name used is taravi
tavi comes from the Arabic word raa
which means to rest which means to relax
because after a few generations
after the prophet People when they used
to read the in Ramadan especially this
word tavi is mainly used for kayam in
Ramadan. So when they used to pray the
kayam in Ramadan after 4:00 they used to
rest. So this word taravi from that time
onwards it got stuck to this in Ramadan
it's called as taravi normally after
4:00 they used to rest and this has
continued because they used to pray for
long hours and even now though they pray
for a short time a few verses yet in the
during Ramadan they stop so the word is
yeti but at the time of the prophet this
word taravi was never used even while
praying during Ramadan this word was
never used even Even the Sahabas never
use this word. It came down later on.
So the more appropriate word is
not the right appropriate word but it
came later on. But if a person when he
reads for a long time Raman if he wants
to rest he can rest but it's not
forbidden to rest. So person is tired
and he wants to rest he can rest but
it's not compulsory. He has to rest. So
the more appropriate word is and it's
not